tsm ceo andy reginald din has publicly
shared the results of an internal and
independent investigation into
accusations of him bullying and creating
a culture of fear at tsm by both former
and current employees this investigation
was publicly announced six months ago
it's been hugely anticipated ever since
but is it really the end of the story
[Music]
okay so by now i imagine a lot of you
watching this will already know the
story up to this point in november 2021
retired league pro and former tsm player
doublelift accused his former boss
reginald of being a bully who made tsm
players cry
he's like a bully who gets away with
being a bad person
because he's powerful because people are
afraid to stand up to him and that's
what i'm sick of so i would just say
that he made a lot of players cry you
would be very surprised
at how many of maybe your your favorite
familiar faces in lcs
legit mental breakdown because of how
badly
they've been getting berated how badly
they were just getting verbally
assaulted
at the time old clips resurfaced online
which were used by people to back up
doublelift's claims for no reason your
argument argument is annoying and you've
always been doing this it's really
getting annoying okay
and lately you've been doing it it's so
annoying
because you're only arguing with me to
argue with me in january this year wyatt
shared their investigation into the
claims which included reports from
former tsm staff that they had allegedly
been subject to mental abuse by reginald
and that they've been dominated by a
culture of fear riot told wyatt that
they were aware of these allegations and
had launched an investigation tsm said
they would also be conducting their own
investigation reginald said he would
recuse himself from the process and
would follow any and all recommendations
from the subcommittee conducting the
investigation last weekend over six
months later the results of tsm's
investigation conducted by the law firm
gutierrez master were finally made
public in a twitlong announcement he
said the investigator spoke to over 30
current and past employees and
contractors including all tsm's current
league of legends players he said they
found no evidence of any unlawful
behavior on the part of the company its
executives or by reginald himself he
added that no witnesses described any
systemic and or isolated incidents of
sexual harassment from there the rest of
the announcement takes a more
introspective turn reginald says he
wants to improve the way he communicates
with team members and that he wants to
be the best ceo he can be he also
acknowledged that when he gave feedback
on employees work by saying that it
creates no value that it wasn't his
intent to make them feel worthless
reginald talked about how in the
beginning of tsm he would joke around
with others by giving them nicknames
such as calling each other pokemon names
or bots but the other employees can now
feel uncomfortable and excluded by this
name-calling for which he'll be more
mindful of going forward as for
practical steps reginald said he'll be
working with an executive coach to
improve his communication and that he'll
be implementing a number of company-wide
initiatives to hold all employees
including himself accountable these
include a three-month evaluation of the
company's culture which will involve all
employees at the company the
implementation of an anonymous reporting
hotline in the workplace and the
facilitating of company workshops with
outside experts to produce a positive
working environment reginald finished
the post by sharing the investigation
summary as a means of transparency the
two-page long document from the
gutierrez marker law firm starts with
something we didn't actually know
beforehand that the investigation was
launched after an employee of swift
tsm's parent company made several
complaints about reginald it was broadly
assumed last year that doublelift's
comments and the public outrage that
followed were what prompted the
investigation however tsm did say at the
time that an investigation was already
on the way so it may have been this the
summary continues by outlining the
investigation conducted by investigator
and attorney lynn david who interviewed
31 current and past employees of tsm and
the other swift companies blitz and icon
as well as all current members of tsm's
league of legends team the investigation
states it found no unlawful conduct from
reginald no witnesses reported
derogatory comments that all female
interviewees did not feel that they were
marginalized and that they found no
cases of sexual harassment or gender
discrimination the summary then
discusses reginald's feedback to
employees which it characterized as
having an aggressive and harsh tone
notably three witnesses of which two are
former employees reported hearing
reginald call employees stupid trash or
worthless the other interviewees who
were asked about this said that reginald
was referring to the work product in
these cases and not the employees
themselves six of the 31 employees
spoken to for past and to current
characterized reginald's conduct as
being a bully who created quote a
culture of fear some people have pointed
out that even one employee experiencing
a culture of fear is noteworthy let
alone almost a fifth of the 31 people
spoken to and then of course there's the
question of the scope of an
investigation that spoke to 31 current
and former employees in a company of
hundreds so
there it is tsm's internal investigation
obviously there's a lot to talk about
here and it didn't take too long for
people's reactions to flood in during a
q a portion of the town hall one long
tenured employee raised questions about
the likelihood of tsm's workplace
culture changing given din's description
of the allegations raised against him as
highly exaggerated the employee also
asked why tsm had alerted sponsors about
the investigation results well in
advance of friday's town hall with
employees the washington post reported
that the same employee accused reginald
of passing them over for a promotion to
which they were allegedly told by
reginald that they quote wouldn't be
able to handle his bullying a phrase
which reginald says he doesn't remember
saying one notable part of the
investigation was its announcement the
reginald hadn't done anything illegal a
former employee who spoke to the
washington post found this strange they
said quote in general the investigation
really seems to focus on the legal
definition of harassment and protected
classes that isn't really what
doublelift or anyone was insinuating to
begin with so that's a little odd this
echoes similar sentiments from others
the reginald being cleared of harassing
people based on their race gender or
religion or of sexually harassing
employees has never been brought up in
any of the public allegations we've seen
so far and speaking of doublelift he was
quick to respond to reginald on twitter
when he shared the investigation summary
he simply said terrible person and you
investigated yourself and no friends and
ratio sure the investigation was
conducted by an outside attorney and law
firm but it was one that was selected by
tsm's investigation subcommittee who
were in turn selected by tsm's board of
directors and this has been memed on a
lot within the league community so far
with the sentiment being that tsm's
investigation simply can't be trusted as
much as a truly externally initiated one
and of course for that we may have to
wait for the results of riot's
investigation wright told the washington
post back in november that they had
begun their investigation into the
allegations of bullying and abuse around
the same time tsm started the
investigation is being conducted by the
law firm o'melviny and myers llp and
wright have given no indication of when
the findings will be released although
the washington post did report the
investigation was extended when the
players association requested the law
firm retained by riot reinterview
certain subjects or reach out to other
subjects who had not yet been contacted
as i've said in previous videos about
all of this before riot isn't beyond the
scrutiny of true impartiality either dsm
is still one of their major lcs brands
and without sounding too cynical people
will likely see the results of their
investigation through that lens of
course they may come to a similar
conclusion to tsm's investigation but
their scope may not be limited to just
whether or not reginald crossed a legal
line their criteria could be very
different and if they conclude that
lines have been overstepped at tsm by
reginald the question of course is what
will they do this story has many
beginnings from the reports and clips
from tsm's early days to the explosive
comments made by doublelift last year
but despite these recent tsm
investigation findings this story is not
over yet as much as reginald may now
want to put this whole thing behind him
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring the notification bell for unique
bite size videos you won't find anywhere
else hit us up on our twitter instagram
facebook and tick tock